donc moi je pense qu'il faut repenser
les vacances et le temps pour pouvoir
avoir plus de temps de sport de culture
de repos et devoirs dans l'année je veux
que nos enfants et nos adolescents
apprennent mieux donc on doit ouvrir ce
sujet donc j'ai dit au ministre et c'est
pas qu'un sujet vacance c'est pour ça
que je le remets en perspective les
grandes vacances c'est la pire des
inégalités
parce que quand vous êtes d'une famille
qui vous fait faire de devoir de
vacances qui a une bibliothèque à la
maison qui vous fait faire du sport qui
vous envoie en vacances en voyage
linguistique à l'étranger vous revenez
en septembre vous avez un écart après
quand vous êtes d'une famille pauvre qui
peut pas partir en vacances
dans un quartier où il y a pas
d'infrastructures sportives vous revenez
vous êtes généralement crevé vous avez
passé des mauvaises vacances et vous
avez dès à prix et ce qui fait que vous
avez on regarde ça a été mesuré un jeune
d'un quartier populaire il revient au
premier septembre il a pas son niveau du
premier juillet il a généralement son
niveau de fin mai mi-mai c'est la pire
des injustices et donc c'est pour ça que
je dis quand on a des évaluations
difficiles ou autre il faut peut-être
pouvoir rentrer un peu plus tôt